there's a section of a most excited
about all day long because today the
second beta guests are calling a beta
open beta 0 beta is it the first open
beta yeah I guess it is for battlefield
one as the first closed beta i put in 22
hours into and i was one map boy that
game was fun you knew that map totally
right yeah and yet I didn't because
every time I played it it was a
different man like it was you know there
were changes to it ray it was a
different level of totally [ __ ]
flattened right are we all in agreement
that the first beta was great mmhmm yeah
we're out pre alpha free for treasure so
this beta is open beta new map it's in
the desert got trains and horses looks
real crazy I'm rob you were the only one
of the three of us who's played it you
played a bunch this morning well I
didn't with me I played like 45 hours at
e3 though okay right so you have you've
you've had experiences as well but Rob
first of all how does it play how is the
new map there was always the worry that
like Oh they've got one good map in the
rain like the rest of the stuff it won't
be as interesting what are your initial
thoughts at this um yeah if I put it in
a couple matches already I think this
this Maps better really yeah what's the
name of it I actually Sinai desert yeah
so you know what's so cool right off the
bat for me was seeing the sandstorms
right and you're getting a different
form of the dynamic weather that they're
like you know putting in these games and
yeah sandstorm and then you get like a
cool overcast cloud covering the Sun so
it's like it just desaturate so
everything in coral down and next thing
you know it's hot again so I think
that's really fun to watch making
craters in the sand is really rewarding
all right great overall it is I feel
like they've added a lot um as far as
like graphics and visual fidelity yeah
it's really looking good and and it
looked quite sure everybody like I did I
mean Ron I was really surprised actually
ran really well on my own pc which is
like pretty good but not like amazing
yeah so yeah um you know I got in a
plane and flew around I'm you know big
advocate of the air combat and that
again they looks like you know before in
the last pre although the planes again
this isn't a finished game
I realize they're working on it but it's
cool to see you know these steps happen
where the plane would hit the ground and
then just disappear kind of ihop yeah I
would that go you're seeing a lot more
wreckage now and when I'm even more
excited about is planes previously you
could shoot up ailerons and then that
would affect your flight controls it
looks like straight up wings are just
gone real fly yeah it was really cool so
you're seeing a lot more of this
destructible nature which is just like
you know I think such an essence of this
game it's really exciting to see so more
of that I got to ride a horse okay yes
so tell me about the horses can you
shoot horses I didn't have the heart
killin but I think okay I think you can
I priorities for today because they kind
of look like they might just be looking
yeah like the motorbikes of this game
right where you're just using it to get
around and find people stuff totally can
you fire one on them yeah if so if you
spawn on the horse you your this kind of
like [ __ ] specific class kind of like
if you're like a tank commander or guile
it you get this like lever action
shotgun right I used a d3 it's it's
tough it's it's one tiny little reticle
like the other guns but you're on the
move and trying to hit someone with this
one shot before you get like a three
second reload right the horse is really
like the horse as much because I kept
getting in tight spots at least when I
played a 3 I don't know if they've been
proven i'm guessing the got pretty like
long turning circles yeah why would you
couldn't turn but the good thing is you
can leap over like low enough walls so
like whereas a jeep would hit this and
then just you'd have to go up on this
mound around the horse justly poles or
do you full control of the horses can
you stop them turn them yeah go anywhere
okay it's not like they're on a preset
path it's got motor cycle that jumps
things okay I agree they're they're cut
off as far as turning like many times I
initially found myself stuck in a corner
so I'm like that and then at that point
you're just you know five people already
looking at you right so you're you're
down maybe to some level of mastery were
like oh two weeks into this will be like
okay that's how you might use those guys
may be right and like it seemed like the
sprint of the horse had like a long
cooldown in the limit amount of like
Santa okay so you know bursts of that I
imagine you get a blade a sword okay so
it was pretty funny crazy ottoman like
bending looking thing
that's better word it's pretty funny
seeing these two guys go at it like
jousting tactics that was pretty wild
what about the train is so the train is
like the Zeppelin of this level writing
the base there call you it's the kind of
like a rubber banding not not so much
but yeah it circles the map now and it's
it looked like destroyed you when I was
watching you but yeah well like watch no
problem has just got big cannons on it
and yeah and spawn into it again I I
wasn't able to get into it because
there's the losing team that guy what
what's funny is uh yeah look like you
could essentially stop the train and
kind of go like whoever's controlling it
definitely thing someone is you can kind
of back up and go around so you okay you
see the the whole outline that map it
looks like it goes around the whole
thing right and it looked like you don't
have to go one way right and take 30
minutes to come back around writing like
that is much more dangerous on the
northern side of the map where those so
the map is the map is actually I
completely agree with Rob it's I think
it's better than San Quentin scar my
first one this map is set up so there's
five control point to the top the
northern side then there's this one
random the e1 is down in this open like
desert and the South go waste this kind
of looking wrong it's cool so top is
like almost built up in the side of a
mountain face and then the track is only
like probably a hundred feet from some
of those so that's when the Train
becomes if I understand the train like
stars the north west point then goes
down so it takes a little bit for it to
get back up north but then once it does
it's super dangerous because it's and
presumably it's also bigger target right
but if like you're the the winning team
you kind of want to try to eradicate it
before it gets up past those flight roll
points that's cool it seemed like it's
definitely close enough you know it's
basically like I'm just moving artillery
oh you can start pummeling the village
up in the north here with us or the but
the the E is the awake oh yeah i think
it's close enough around there so that's
like a valuable things look ok basically
it gives reason to go around the old map
right yeah another thing yeah you
mentioned the map which i am a huge fan
up is again air combat is great like I'm
a huge advocate of steep terrain and in
valleys outmaneuver people sure enough
you know they have like like San arches
that you could fly under and like really
hog and can fly between the canyons um
when you're when you're able to
utilize you the terrain in a plane to
like your advantage I get something or
six and you can kind of like you know
who's a better pilot but let me hug this
corner it's all I had to do like mission
or independence day style yeah like just
yeah whoo yeah so you're seeing that I
think that's that's pretty great as far
as there's a there's a few new weapons
they kind of pull back on some things
too okay it's like they took out some
weapons but they've added like assault
class is basically you know compared to
the previous game if like they just
meshed engineer and assault rifle you're
very much an anti-tank anti-vehicle guy
now so they added dynamite so you can
throw down dynamite google it up perfect
for the train you're making crazy you
could like ostensibly make what you did
you were making craters earlier at e
that southern outpost if you had like no
cover if the building is ready to make a
crater and duck into it right right and
you totally need to because it it's so
far away there are just these stretches
of sand dunes which are fun to hit with
the g bows but yeah you you're gonna
need cover because i was in a plane and
toots five dudes are just running across
the sand dune trying to get to e do i
was just knocking oh yeah just rotation
yeah yeah oh that's excellent uh i think
it's a much more diverse map and i think
this looks great again like for
something as simple as overcast right in
a desert yeah and which is like a pretty
monochromatic area i think we as like is
weird to get it super geeky it's this
weird like confluence of the
mediterranean weather and the desert
weather right oh so this is actually you
don't care what the history of now go
for it alright so as the sinai campaign
british were essentially just trying to
control suez canal against the ottoman
empire it actually got kind of like
overlooked but it was like I took a
while i was like 1915 until ride 16 you
said it was like almost like the world
war two marker course i will in version
of market garden well Gallipoli was in
the australians land and we're trying to
like pierce the ottoman empire this was
more a defensive thing on the british
all right but i don't know like I don't
want to talk to the full game before it
comes out October because again this is
a beta but this map what it like excites
me about it is that like obviously
Battlefield games live or die by their
level design their maps as most shooters
do but battlefield even more so
definitely this one you
we play the entire game differently i
was telling rob like San Quentin scar
felt like there's wide open space and it
was good for like different viewpoints
and sniping and like vehicles would be
better up certain approaches but that
felt like this big battlefield where
there were these separate skirmishes
raging all over a different control
points south and the north were like two
different things right and this one
still kind of like that but the fact
that the train you can't control where
it's going the train is actually
circling the map and also the fact that
there's just one lone outpost it
actually feels like the entire thing is
one big cohesive battle because there's
canyons so when I was planning III like
my team was trying to push out of these
canyons we took the central village the
north and then we were pushing them back
into their canyons but then the
sandstorm whipped in so they like I
don't know if they meant to or not but
they took the chance because we were a
lot of us were sniping they took a
chance for the concealment to come and
push us back whereas like the next time
I played me and six other guys and I
just went down held EV for the entirety
of the map and like when the train came
really oh my god we just like hunkered
down like five of us died there's like a
couple has left but it feels that's why
I like Bell feel one is exciting me
right now again I can't speak to the
quality full game i have played it like
no one has but it actually feels like
they're these you have a sense of the
overarching battle that you don't in
like a lot of other games and even like
recent Battlefield games yeah and ian i
mean i am fascinated to see what people
think of this open beta because we have
a lot of like I think like I think it's
fair to say like a lot of us are bout of
your fans but we're also like skeptics
like coming out of three and four for
Mosley is that like oh yeah yeah like
but like there's been nothing but we've
enjoyed so much of playing the original
beta and it sounds like this one's
fascinating as well from what you guys
are saying so I can't wait because like
you know the price can talk about it for
as long as we want but it's not until
people actually get hold of it that we
can kind of like you see that like tide
change and I really think like this is
the best but it seems already like it
might be the best battlefield let's come
in a long time and yeah we haven't seen
any of the campaign yet either right
yeah i mean like that's a majority of
people that's not the main draw I
between like having a background in like
looking at World War 1 history but also
just the fact that like if they can
talking about like other people like how
big a part video games playing
romanticizing war knows like because you
movies did that for a while the 50s and
60s and like the 70s comes along you
have the deer hunter and then the
eighties comes along you put two
those movies realize is kind of messed
up to do that whereas games are still in
entrenched in this like romantis a shin
and you have people yeah spending sixty
dollars and pre-orders to play a game
set during the some of the worst moments
in human is rise like yeah not to get
like to pc about it but like if they can
actually use that and kind of examine
like how messed up world war one was
that's interesting me but if they just
kind of exploit it i guess i'm just
gonna stick the multiplayer again but
i'm curious about the campaign because
even just for the sake of having new
types of games to play like we've played
like medal of honor was very much start
and they were amazing call of duty was
very much off at the first couple of
years and those are amazing but yeah
you're right like it would be great like
spec ops the line is one of the most
interesting that's the one like like
stories about war I've ever seen I like
it's basically like a video game version
of a popular movie but like I like it's
a yeah like I'd love to see more of that
stuff not just for the sake of like war
is bad but also just because games
haven't really explored that at all yeah
anyway and you're right like if there
was ever a war to do it like world war
one whenever you like do your little
Wikipedia search every couple of years
and learn about it it's like man this
was uh yeah words and that's why they
said it was the Great War cuz we'll
never do this again oh [ __ ] we're doing
it again it's really bad it's like the
obviously the Geneva Convention like so
many rules about the rules about war now
because of where we're one yeah not
anybody amazed oh he died not even in
the bottles like I just bend across the
world as a man influenza first anak
first-hand accounts of like uh not to
get I don't wanna get too graphic but
like first-hand accounts was like trench
like just living in trenches after a
while the trench itself is just like
coated in yeah it's coated and just like
all sorts of human feces and in like
humans alright alright gone a sludge
that people describe that God's cussing
it's tough to yeah so I know how the
campaign just yeah uh need more watch oh
my god you really see the slow your by
this problem job yeah late in 4k you
really got the sludge look at this slide
yeah what is that a are you like driven
it just have this idea of like this
matrix like
purple goo Ritz well Harvey to be
secretly owes me two people that stuff
that they were in they like to our
matrix you think that stuff there a min
the thing pods was also made of like
demons are batteries in that room yeah
dad bet that's what you do with dead
batteries yeah
[Music]